[Musique]
adaptation de l'album de jeunesse de
tomi ungerer les trois brigands c'est
l'histoire de trois voyous qui chaque
soir des trousses des voyageurs un
spectacle qui tourne autour de leur
rencontre avec une petite orpheline des
protagonistes que tout oppose l'histoire
racontera pas qu'est-ce qui va naître de
cette rencontre et comment ces trois
brigands
vonvon comment cette petite fille va
finalement bouleverser la vie de ces
trois de ces trois de ces trois affreux
jojo et
comment ils vont trouver une implication
sociale différente il veut pas dire
qu'ils arrêteront de voler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le mot
[Applaudissements]
le spectacle à 5 ans co produit par la
compagnie les miettes bavarder la
compagnie les petites donne quichotte au
programme marionnettes théâtre et une
dimension musicale a portés au compte
cet aspect ctaq le musical qui fait
venir au théâtre un grand compositeur
il n'avait jamais composées pour pour
laquelle les paroles pour des textes
donc je pense que c est des grands
interprètes aussi
sébastien innocenti lisandro donoso sont
des bancs donner aux niches est très
reconnu aujourd'hui à l'international
rendez vous au théâtre du montansier
mercredi 12 janvier à 15 heures pour
découvrir le spectacle